♪ ♪
>> IF THE REPUBLICANS ARE
LOOKING FOR SOMEBODY TO TURN
THIS PROCESS INTO A FOOD FIGHT,
LOOK NO FURTHER THAN JIM JORDAN.
>> HE ALONE IS ONE OF THE MOST
DISRUPTIVE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
AND WILL DO AS MUCH AS HE
POSSIBLY CAN TO HIJACK AND BE
THEATRICAL.
>> SOUNDING LIKE A JIM JORDAN,
WHO IS A WALKING CLOWN SHOW ONTO
A VERY SERIOUS COMMITTEE IS JUST
A VERY RIDICULOUS IDEA.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN JORDAN
JOINS US NOW.
ISN'T IT FUN BEING SOLD OFF?
I FEEL THE SAME WAY LATELY
DOESN'T IT GIVE YOU THE WARM AND
FUZZIES, THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE
THE AND AT THE PICNIC OF THE
JANUARY 6TH COMMISSION.
>> I TELL MY COLLEAGUES ALL THE
TIME, IF THE MAINSTREAM PRESS
AND THE LIBERAL DEMOCRATS AREN'T
SAYING ANYTHING BAD ABOUT YOU
THAN I AM NOT DOING ANYTHING
GOOD.
YOU ARE FIGHTING THE GOOD FIGHT
AND YOU GET ATTACKED ALL THE
TIME.
WILL THEY KICK ME OFF OF THE
COMMITTEE, I DON'T KNOW.
SINCE WHEN DOES THE OTHER COACH
TO DETERMINE WHO GETS TO PLAY
FOR OUR TEAMS THAT WE WILL SEE
WHAT HAPPENS.
BUT I DO KNOW WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT, THIS IS ABOUT ATTACKING
PRESIDENT TRUMP ONCE AGAIN
BECAUSE FRANKLY, WHAT ELSE ARE
THEY GOING TO TALK ABOUT?
AT THE GOING TO TALK ABOUT CRIME
GOING UP IN EVERY CITY,
INFLATION, WHERE THE PRICE OF
EVERYTHING, GAS, BREAD, MILK,
AIRLINE TICKETS, USED CARS, ARE
THEY GOING TO TALK ABOUT THAT
STUFF?
SO THEY HAVE TO FOCUS ON THE
ONLY THING THEY KNOW WHICH IS
ATTACKING PRESIDENT TRUMP
BECAUSE HE DID SUCH A GOOD JOB
AND THEY CAN'T STAND THAT.
>> Laura: THEIR PAL AOC HAS A
FEW THOUGHTS ON YOUR BEING
CHOSEN FOR THE JANUARY 6TH
COMMISSION.
WATCH.
>> KEVIN McCARTHY HAS DECIDED
THAT HIS ROLE AS THE MINORITY
LEADER IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES IS ESSENTIALLY
TO BE CHAUFFEUR OF THE CLOWN CAR
AND HE BELIEVES THAT HIS JOB IS
TO CHAMPION SOME OF THE MOST
LUDICROUS, RESPONSIBLE AND
DANGEROUS MEMBERS OF THIS PARTY
INSTEAD OF CENTERING SOME OF THE
MORE EVEN KILLED AND RESPONSIBLE
MEMBERS OF HIS PARTY.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN JORDAN,
THE RESPONSIBLE MEMBERS OF THE
PARTY, PEOPLE LIKE
ADAM KINZINGER AND OTHERS, THEY
WOULD AGREE WITH THE DEMOCRATS
THAT THIS WAS AN INSURRECTION
UNLIKE ANY WORLDWIDE
INSURRECTION THAT HAS EVER
OCCURRED.
>> IF THEY WANT TO USE THE TERM
RESPONSIBLE, YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD
BE RESPONSIBLE?
TO ASK THE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION,
WHY WASN'T THERE A PROPER
SECURITY PRESENCE AND POSTURE
THAT DAY AND FRANKLY THE ONLY
ONE WHO CAN ANSWER THAT IS
SPEAKER PELOSI.
BUT MY HUNCH IS THE REASON WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE BACKUP THERE FOR
THOSE GOOD CAPITOL HILL POLICE
OFFICERS IS BECAUSE WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE SUMMER OF 2020,
DEMOCRATS NORMALIZED ANARCHY.
IF YOU ATTACKED POLICE OFFICERS,
DESTROYED SMALL BUSINESS, THEY
SAID THAT'S FINE.
THEY CALLED IT A PEACEFUL
PROTEST AND WORSE YET THEY
RAISED MONEY TO BAIL THOSE VERY
PEOPLE OUT OF JAIL.
WITH THAT AS A BACKDROP YOU
PROBABLY CAN'T HAVE THE KIND OF
PRESENCE YOU NEED WHEN YOU'RE
HAVING THIS KIND OF -- OF PEOPLE
COMING TO THE CAPITAL.
I DOUBT IF THE DEMOCRATS WOULD
ADDRESS THAT QUESTION BUT THAT
WOULD BE THE RESPONSIBLE THING
TO DO.
>> Laura: YES OR NO, SHOULD
NANCY PELOSI BE THE SUBJECT OF
AN INVESTIGATION?
>> SHE SHOULD HAVE TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION, WHY WASN'T THERE A
BETTER SECURITY PRESENCE THAT
DAY?